c'est aussi pour lui parce que
voilà si qu'il soit pas parti pour rien
qu'il est pas fait ça pour rien
que s'il a choisi cette solution extrême
c'est que il en a pas trouvé d'autres
donc oui c'est c'est lui reconnaître
c'est une victime
l'école un lieu protégé un sanctuaire ou
chaque enfant devrait pouvoir apprendre
à lire à écrire ou simplement jouer avec
ses camarades en toute sécurité
mais trop souvent les salles de classe
les couloirs la cour de récréation
devienne un enfer
jacky est devenu le soufre-douleur de sa
classe chaque jour était une épreuve il
a survécu et veut partager son histoire
Alexandre lui n'a pas eu cette chance à
bout il a décidé de mettre fin à ses
jours depuis sa maman Gaëlle mène un
combat contre le harcèlement à l'école
j'ai eu envie de mieux comprendre
pourquoi la vie d'un enfant peut à ce
point basculer et surtout comment éviter
ça
[Musique]
je m'appelle Jacky pamar j'ai été
victime de harcèlement scolaire
je m'appelle Gaëlle tranchant je suis la
maman d'Alexandre victime de harcèlement
scolaire
[Musique]
insulter moquer et humilié
quotidiennement Jacky et Alexandre ont
été victimes de harcèlement de la part
de leur camarades deux trajectoires
d'adolescents frappés par la violence
des cours de récréation
Jacky essaie de se reconstruire après
les terribles épreuves qu'il a traversé
durant un an
Alexandre lui n'a pas pu résister à la
pression exercée par les autres élèves
et à choisir une solution extrême
ses parents qui doivent réapprendre à
vivre malgré son absence cherche à
rendre justice à leur fils
[Musique]
depuis presque un an Gaëlle tranchant
vient régulièrement dans cette chambre
où son fils Alexandre a mis fin à ses
jours le 23 février 2013
[Musique]
donc là on est dans la chambre
d'Alexandre
je suis presque par l'odeur sentir sa
présence donc c'est vrai que c'est le
premier truc qui me qui me qui me prend
quand je rentre ici et puis généralement
je reste pas longtemps je voilà je me
balade je regarde son panpan je suis
caresse le nez parce que c'était un
tique qu'il avait pris c'est dans sa
chambre d'enfant au milieu de ces jouets
qu'Alexandre a décidé de se donner la
mort brisant ainsi le bonheur de ses
parents longtemps ils vont hésiter à
quitter le domicile familial on s'est
dit ce qu'on sera capable de continuer à
vivre dans l'endroit où Alexandre est
parti mais ça a été la maison dans
laquelle on a partagé tellement de
bonnes choses tellement de bonheur il y
a eu tellement de bons moments moi je
vois plus un endroit un endroit de
bien-être
nous sommes en 1998 après de nombreuses
tentatives infructueuses Gaëlle tombe
finalement enceinte Alexandre est le
petit miracle de la famille
c'était donc mon fils unique et c'était
ma vie
puisque ben voilà j'ai eu du mal à la
voir donc c'est vrai quand il a
excusez-moi
quand on a eu le bonheur de le voir
arriver dans notre vie c'était voilà
c'était mon rayon de soleil c'était ma
raison de vivre
la vie de famille se construit alors
autour de ce petit garçon plein de
vitalité comme c'est un enfant très
vivant en fait il est que il sortait de
la pièce on s'en apercevait dessus parce
qu'il manquait quelque chose quand il
était il prenait beaucoup d'espaces
beaucoup de place et nous ça nous
convenait tout à fait puisque on avait
décidé de d'avoir un enfant aussi pour
ça très vite Alexandre curieux de tout
développe des centres d'intérêts peu
communs pour son âge
qu'il était passionné par tout ce qui
est le domaine scientifique par
l'archéologie par l'espace
l'aéronautique enfin il y avait beaucoup
de choses qui le passionnaient puis il
était content aussi de d'en parler mais
Alexandre fait aussi partie d'un club de
foot Gilles son père l'emmenait
régulièrement à ses entraînements il
garde un souvenir ému de tous les
moments qu'il partageaient avec lui
et donc on est deux fois deux fois le
soir dans la semaine il avait
entraînement
[Musique]
donc moi je restais là-bas pour lui
[__] la paix et puis je laisse son
petit son petit business
on se baladait en bécane ensemble on
allait manger ensemble
je l'emmenais là au foot en l'entend
c'est moi qui l'amenait pour les matchs
bon vu que je suis pas un grand
passionné de foot c'était plus la
recherche de sa mère les grands matchs
une vie simple pour Alexandre partager
entre le bonheur familial et les copains
d'école c'est une équipe de copains
avant d'être une équipe de foot au bout
de deux semaines d'entraînement il était
complètement faisait partie de l'équipe
mais Alex
Andre d'Ét
[Musique]
ablissement est arrivé sur Carcassonne
je dirais ça a été un petit peu plus
difficile
de par sa personnalité et de ses
connaissances et ce qui l'intéressait
c'est vrai que c'était pas forcément ce
que les ados de maintenant je dirais
attendez de d'un camarade
arrivé dans son nouveau collège
Alexandre a beaucoup de mal à partager
ses passions avec ses nouveaux camarades
pire encore il devient l'un des premiers
de sa classe une véritable tard pour les
autres élèves voilà parce qu'on
participe en classe du coup voilà on est
considéré comme le premier de la classe
parce qu'on a des bonnes notes et il y a
une espèce de système qui se met en
place malheureusement et voilà c'est du
coup il se retrouve en marge et
considéré comme différent parce qu'ils
ont pas les mêmes passions que les
autres
sa passion pour les sciences et
l'archéologie se développe et c'est à
cause de cette différence que les jeunes
de sa classe vont commencer à le rejeter
en famille et bon élève alexandre se
sent rejeté par ses camarades qui vont
peu à peu commencer à se moquer de lui
et le mettre à l'écart
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que Jacky revient
dans l'enceinte du collège Georges
Brassens là où il a passé son année de
6e
donc là on est dans la salle
d'histoire-géographie
donc moi j'étais installé toute l'année
ici ce qu'on avait les toujours les
mêmes places et voilà toute l'année
j'étais là
mais c'est aussi entre ces murs que
Jacky a connu l'enfer du harcèlement
la sonnerie c'est un signal qui marquait
la différence entre deux environnements
donc là où j'étais en classe donc là oui
il m'avait rien parce qu'il y avait le
prof et l'autre côté donc là où donc
dans les couloirs les créations la pose
de midi donc et c'est là où se déroulait
les violences
[Musique]
Jacky apparaît comme un petit garçon
rêveur il était différent au sens que
les autres garçons c'était plus le
ballon enfin les petites voitures mon
Jacky tout ce qui est sport pas possible
et il a vraiment une sensibilité Jacky
donc ça fait qu'il était un peu dans son
dans son monde on va dire
mais très vite Jacky développe un
bégaiement prononcé pour ce petit garçon
sensible chaque moment de vie devient
une véritable épreuve
c'est dur de créer le contact et aussi
en dehors pour aller chercher du pain
faire les courses tout ça c'est assez
compliqué en fait à chaque fois je
voyais ça comme un défi ça me stressait
mais j'étais content de pouvoir le faire
en fait
Jacky arrive à dépasser ce handicap au
quotidien mais c'est lorsqu'il est
confronté à des jeunes de son âge que
son bégaiement lui pèse le plus en
primaire au fil du temps au fil des
classes c'est là où les remarques
vexantes se sont mis à
apparaître donc bon ça ne m'était pas
non plus très très mal mais bon c'était
un peu pesant
malgré les moqueries Jacky parvient à
s'intégrer et vit une primaire sans
encombre mais c'est à son arrivée en 6e
que les choses se compliquent Jacky se
retrouve seul séparé de ses amis du
primaire
quand je suis arrivée dans ma nouvelle
classe de 6e je ne connaissais pas grand
monde les seuls noms que je connaissais
c'était des personnes qui se moquaient
de moi en fait en primaire donc c'est
vrai que mon n'était pas très proche
évidemment
très vite les simples brimades font
place aux insultes blessantes qui
ponctuaient de mots violents sont
répétés quotidiennement
quand on a ces insultes tous les jours
par plusieurs personnes mais on se dit
bon bah c'est le monde le dit c'est
peut-être vrai ça c'est une réflexion
totalement idiote mais on est on se la
pose en fait on se dit ça c'est qu'un
prof c'est qu'un pro c'est un problème
quoi c'est jacky est alors persuadé que
le problème vient de lui il préfère
s'isoler des autres élèves et en
caisser en protester mais la situation
va devenir bien plus compliquée quand il
va croiser la route d'une bande d'élèves
de croisière particulièrement agressif
c'est un jour où j'étais en retard
j'avais cours au troisième étage je me
suis mis à courir dans les couloirs et
en fait il y a la poignée du cartable
qui a été au niveau du haut de mon dos
en fait ils ont pris avec leurs mains
cette poignée et ils sont amusés à jouer
avec moi en fait
[Musique]
puis c'est après qu'ils m'ont projeté
contre un mur
et c'est là j'ai eu quelques points
quelques coups de pied très bref sur le
corps
et ensuite ils m'ont
lâché bien que choqué par cette violente
attaque Jacky préfère oublier l'incident
à ce moment là il pense à un événement
isolé
toujours peur d'être des 3e donc je me
suis dit peut-être que ça arrivera une
fois et que ça se verra pas donc j'ai
pas j'ai pas accordé trop d'importance à
ce qui s'était passé seulement les
violences et les intimidations vont se
répéter fréquemment jusqu'à devenir le
quotidien du jeune homme
c'était presque tout le temps la même
chose c'était une parfaite parfaite
répétition tout le temps
à force de comporter chaque jour le
corps de Jacky
[Musique]
écoute harceleur ne font rien au hasard
tout est calculé j'ai aussi le souvenir
vague que il y en a un qui s'est mis à
me faire un coup derrière la tête et que
ainsi camarades dit non non ne fait
surtout pas ça là on va le voir après il
va aller se plaindre tout ça
malgré sa peur grandissante
Jacky ne parle à personne de ce qu'il
subit au quotidien
le mot balance
circulait énormément donc je vous
voulais pas en parler et puis il y avait
un autre phénomène que je ne peux
toujours pas expliquer c'est que j'avais
honte de ce qui marque IV comme ça un
problème qui me concerne moi le
bégaiement
j'ai tout de suite remis la faute sur
moi ses sentiments de culpabilité et de
honte poussent l'adolescent à se taire à
la maison il fait tout pour cacher son
mal-être et ne laisse rien transparaître
auprès de ses parents pour sa mère rien
dans le comportement de Jacky ne
laissait imaginer un quotidien si
terrifiant
il y a pas eu de changements même au
niveau de ses résultats et il a fait une
très bonne sixième
donc non Jacky voilà c'est
un garçon calme il rentrait faisait ses
leçons enfin on n'a pas vu de changement
quoi
rien d'étonnant puisque Jacky a
consciemment tout fait pour masquer son
mal-être et préserver le bonheur
familial j'ai pas envie de rentrer le
soir et de dire ah voilà il s'est passé
à ça pour encore en parler et pour
inclure ce qui se passait au collège
dans le cercle familial donc j'avais
établi aussi une frontière entre chez
moi vous me direz rien ou je profitais
des moments avec ma famille et le
collège voilà je ça c'était carrément
exclu et je ne voulais pas
[Musique]
vous êtes psychologue on le voit avec
Jacky les enfants victimes de
harcèlement refusent souvent d'en parler
à leurs parents ou à leur professeurs
comment l'expliquer les victimes se
replient sur elle c'est juste parce que
c'était un élève déjà seul déjà isolé
déjà fragile qu'il ne va d'autant plus
pas parler il a honte il y a très
souvent la honte aussi qui en parle de
parler c'est ça ouais pourquoi la honte
et la culpabilité quand on est victime
parce qu'on est atteint dans son
intimité c'est à dire que dans le
harcèlement tout est fait pour blesser
tout est fait pour détruire l'estime de
soi tu es nul tu vaux rien et l'enfant
finit par l'intégrer est-ce qu'il y a
des agresseurs type des portraits robots
ce qu'on remarque quand même c'est que
lorsqu'on creuse un peu les choses
victimes et auteurs ont des points
communs ce sont des enfants généralement
plus fragiles que les autres mais l'un
va être dans sa fragilité et l'autre va
masquer sa fragilité par des redomontas
par des violences pour masquer ce point
faible un point commun également à tous
et harcèlements c'est la loi du silence
partagée par les enfants il ne peut pas
y avoir de harcèlement sans les
complices les complices ce sont les
autres ce sont les autres enfants
généralement dans le harcèlement les
adultes ne vont pas voir en revanche les
autres élèves savent connaissent c'est
dur aussi pour un enfant de faire la
part des choses savoir ce qui doit le
dire ou pas ça c'est pas simple donc le
critère c'est quand on voit quelqu'un
qui a mal quelqu'un qui souffre on doit
en parler
[Musique]
en cachant ses problèmes Jacky pense
pouvoir contenir le calvaire qu'il vit
derrière les murs du collège
mais ces bourreaux ne comptent pas en
rester là
[Musique]
entrer en 6e dans un collège où il ne
connaît personne Alexandre peine à
trouver sa place
fasciné par les domaines scientifiques
il est confronté à un rejet brutal de la
part de ses camarades qui ne comprennent
pas ces centres d'intérêts les moqueries
ne tarde pas à apparaître
Alexandre souffre de cette situation et
en parle à sa mère
j'arrivais à savoir les choses qu'il
touchaient vraiment donc c'est vrai de
cet aspect là de passer d'amis peut-être
trop petit tu es trop gros plus d'autres
insultes qui ont fusé un moment bon j'ai
senti que ça le
ça le touchait à ce moment là Gaëlle
n'est pas inquiète elle pense à de
simples jeux d'adolescents
je me suis dit c'est des bêtises de
gamins et ça va passer il y a un moment
où ils vont le laisser tomber parce que
soit il aura grandi soit je sais pas il
aura changé ou il aura une copine j'en
sais rien ils vont lui fiche la paix et
puis et puis ça s'arrêtera là quoi
ne pouvant pas se douter de la gravité
de la situation elle conseille
simplement à son fils de se défendre
donc juillet mais par contre il faut pas
te laisser faire il faut il faut que tu
aies un petit peu de caractère pour te
dire bon il y a un moment de dire stop
ça suffit quelqu'un t'insulte et ben tu
lui dis stop il comprend pas tu lui
réponds mais c'est l'heure de son entrée
en troisième en septembre 2012 que la
situation va empirer pour le jeune
garçon
quasiment des dès la rentrée de 3e j'ai
senti quelque chose à l'épa parce que
voilà il le considérait un peu comme
comme un alien parce que bah il avait
pas les mêmes centres d'intérêt que et
là ça a été je pense plus marqué par
rapport aux autres années 4ème 5ème 6ème
voilà là on a commencé je pense à s'en
prendre plus à lui dans sa classe un
collégien en particulier va le prendre
pour cible entre insultes raillerie vole
et raquette quotidien le harcèlement
s'intensifie Gaëlle se souvient d'un
jour particulièrement éprouvant pour son
fils il ressort de l'école en pleurant
cette fois-ci
bon qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il me dit
bah écoute ce fameux élève X
quand on est arrivé dans la classe donc
il avait rangé son casque et son MP3
dans son sac il m'a dit il a pris mon
sac il l'a projeté à travers la classe
et du coup mon casque est cassé
mais ce jour-là s'en est trop la mère
d'Alexandre décide d'en parler à la
direction du collège
j'explique l'histoire je lui dis c'est
toujours l'élève X qui embête à
Alexandre donc là j'ai comment dire je
me suis pas fâchée mais voilà je lui ai
dit ça fait deux fois que je me déplace
pour ce
enfin c'était x je dis à un moment si
vous arrivez pas à régler le problème
c'est moi qui vais m'en occuper
mais vous inquiétez pas on a compris on
va régler les choses et bon
rassurer Gaëlle pense que l'affaire est
réglée d'autant que son fils ne lui
parle plus de ses problèmes
donc quand je lui posais des questions
savoir comment ça se passait à l'école
si l'élève x l'embêtait encore
il me répondait vaguement partez vite
sur autre chose donc moi oui j'ai cru
que les choses avaient changé
les choses semblent donc s'arranger pour
le jeune Alexandre à la fin du deuxième
trimestre les élèves doivent effectuer
un stage de découverte en entreprise
Alexandre est heureux puisqu'il vient
d'être accepté par un laboratoire
vétérinaire de la ville une semaine loin
des ennuis scolaires
et là j'ai retrouvé mon Alexandre quoi
c'était le soir pendant 1h30 nous
parlait de tout ce qu'il avait fait
parce qu'il faisait des expériences il a
pris je sais pas au moins 300 photos fin
de là il s'est dit maman j'ai trouvé ma
voix
mais quand Gaëlle va chercher son fils
ce vendredi soir dernier jour de stage
il semble étrangement abattu là je l'ai
senti très triste
il m'a dit écoute maman je veux
travailler dans le laboratoire c'est
vraiment ça que je veux faire j'ai plus
envie d'aller à l'école puis je dis pour
être biologiste il faut quand même que
tu fasses un petit peu d'études donc je
lui dis ça peut pas non je dis tu peux
pas continuer tu as que 14 ans il faut
aller un petit peu à l'école et puis
après tu pourras faire ce que tu veux
il rentrer
ont conscient que la semaine de vacances
scolaires va être chargée
le samedi matin Gaëlle découvre un petit
mot tendre laissé par son fils à son
attention je retrouve une lettre sur la
table du salon avec mon prénom écrit
dessus donc je l'ouvre et là il y a un
petit papier écrit je t'aime
parce que je me suis dit il est mignon
bon c'est vrai que j'ai des petits je
t'aime comme ça on en a partout donc je
vais faire un bisou je dis merci mon
pauvre mon poussin parce qu'il a fait
poussin mais avant de partir ensemble
visiter la Cité de l'Espace de Toulouse
Gaëlle exige que son fils range sa
chambre
c'est vraiment c'était l'apocalypse je
dis écoute Alexandre ça suffit
maintenant je suis que tu ranges ta
chambre parce que je dis sinon on fera
pas la moitié des choses qu'on a prévu
de faire
et bon il a rouspété un peu donc c'est
vrai que bon j'ai un peu haussé le ton
j'ai des coups de maintenant ça suffit
il faut que tu ranges ta chambre après
c'est accrochage avec son fils Gaëlle
descend rejoindre son mari devant la
télévision mais une heure plus tard
Alexandre n'est toujours pas descendu je
pense c'était vers 2h bon j'entendais
plus trop j'entendais plus trop j'ai je
vais voir où il en est comme je faisais
d'habitude donc je suis monté j'ai
ouvert la porte
et ma première action
quand je l'ai vu
pendu à son lit
j'ai cru qu'il me faisait une blague et
là j'ai vu que c'était pas une blague
[Musique]
Gaëlle appelle immédiatement les secours
arrivée sur place les pompiers sont
impuissants ils ne peuvent que constater
le décès d'Alexandre
[Musique]
et
à ce moment là on est mort
on est mort avec lui
il y a pas d'autres
Damiani le témoignage de Gaëlle est
absolument bouleversant comment est-ce
qu'on peut concevoir qu'un enfant puisse
passer à l'acte et se donner la mort
alors c'est toujours complexe un suicide
il y a toujours un ensemble de raisons
c'est c'est pas linéaire c'est à dire il
y a telle raison et il s'est suicidé
pour ça et ce serait vraiment réducteur
de dire
ça s'est passé pour cette raison là en
tout cas mais c'est vrai que les
adolescents sont dans une période déjà
fragile et ils peuvent tout à fait
s'autodétruire en allant jusque là alors
il peut y avoir plusieurs phases
d'autodestruction il y en a qui peuvent
se scarifier arrêter de manger etc
heureusement ils sont rares à aller
jusqu'au passager à aussi que souvent
les agresseurs se rendent pas compte
finalement de la pression qu'ils mettent
la gravité de leurs actes lorsqu'on est
confronté à des à du harcèlement il y a
une espèce de banalisation de la part
des autres élèves ils ne se rendent pas
compte de du poids des mots qui peuvent
avoir je me souviens par exemple d'une
cas d'une jeune fille où les autres
élèves lui disaient des grosses étaient
moches avec la tête que tu as tu le
ressautée par la fenêtre jusqu'au jour
il a vraiment sauté par la fenêtre et ça
les élèves avaient du mal quasiment à
faire le lien entre ce qu'ils avaient
dit ce qu'elle avait fait
effondrée Gaëlle va chercher à
comprendre ce qui a poussé son fils à
mettre fin à ses jours
[Musique]
malgré la souffrance qu'il vit à
l'intérieur du collège Jacky sait qu'une
fois les portes franchies ils retrouvera
un semblant de liberté
malheureusement pour lui ses agresseurs
ne se satisfont plus des violences à
l'école
ils se mettent à le poursuivre à
l'extérieur de l'établissement
habitant dans un petit village éloigné
du collège Jacky prend le bus pour
rentrer chez lui à la fin des cours
et c'est lors de ces trajets que les
jeunes harceleurs vont poursuivre leur
jeu cruel
il y avait un arrêt qui était assez
extirpé de la ville enfin du petit
village et il y en a qui appuyaient
dessus en maison donc le chauffeur est
obligé de s'arrêter donc il voyait que
personne descendait puis il disait que
celui qui a appuyé il sort donc ceux qui
me faisaient du mal la journée que je
retrouvais dans le bus me désigner donc
plusieurs fois je suis descendu à cette
heure-là
j'ai fini l'arrêt à pied et en fait au
bout de la route il m'attendait en fait
et répliquer ce qui faisait en journée
pour Jacky il n'y a pas d'issue possible
face à ce calvaire incessant
il n'allait pas arrêter
moi je ne voulais pas en parler donc
la seule solution que je voyais et qui
est bien sûr
la fosse et que aujourd'hui j'ai un peu
honte d'avoir pensé à ça bah j'ai pensé
au suicide en fait
[Musique]
donc j'ai trouvé l'accord de dans le
garage on en a plein donc c'est pas un
problème
puis je fais un effort mais je me suis
balancé sur le rond de la corde pour
voir si elle allait tenir le poids et la
tenue donc je suis voilà
il est prêt à passer à l'acte Jacky
monte sur une chaise et passe la corde
autour de son cou
[Musique]
c'est bizarre mais je pensais au
soulagement que ça me procurait
voilà j'avais peur mais j'ai beaucoup
plus français à ce sentiment de
soulagement je me suis dit mais enfin
voilà ça va être fini mais avant de
franchir le pas fatidique Jacky
s'accorde une dernière pensée pour ses
parents
je me suis mais
comment ils vont réagir quand ils vont
découvrir là sans vie dans la chambre je
me suis dit
c'est pour ça que j'ai longtemps en fait
c'était pas pour moi puisque moi j'étais
terminé mais c'était pour voilà pour eux
mais je voulais pas qu'ils sont de
coupable
[Musique]
soudain sa mère l'appelle pour venir
manger c'est le signal qui va le ramener
à la raison
je crois
elle rigole quand je lui en parle mais
moi je crois vrai je crois vraiment
qu'elle a senti que ça allait pas piqué
qui m'a appelé et puis qu'elle m'a sauvé
la vie
tout simplement voilà
Jacky renonce se suicide mais il n'avoue
toujours pas à ses parents le supplice
qui l'endurent à l'école
[Musique]
suite au décès de leur fils Gaëlle et
Gilles sont anéanties je pouvais plus
m'alimenter je pourrais on n'a pas pu
dormir
ça a été
là on s'est retrouvé plongé en plein
cauchemar et ça a été la première nuit
ça a été la deuxième nuit ça a été comme
ça et ça l'est toujours pour Gaëlle
c'est le désarroi total à la douleur se
mêle l'incompréhension elle commence à
se demander ce qui a pu pousser son fils
etarable bien sûr qu'on commence à se
poser des questions ou se dire mais
c'est moi qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait qu'est-ce qu'on a
pas fait
et puis après on essaie d'espèces de
mener une espèce d'analyse et de se dire
mais pourquoi le soir il m'a dit qu'il
voulait plus retourner à l'école
pourquoi il m'a laissé un je t'aime je
dis qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
elle décide d'aller voir sur
l'ordinateur de son fils si elle peut
trouver des indices expliquant le drame
sans regardant sur ces pages que je j'ai
commencé à comprendre en fait bah voilà
qui avait qui avait des choses qui
n'étaient pas très normales au niveau de
l'école qui des messages comment dire
assez explicites sur ce que vivent
Alexandre et donc c'est à partir de là
que j'ai commencé à me lancer dans mes
recherches et essayer de remonter un peu
l'histoire qui avait pu vivre Alexandre
en naviguant de pas en page Gael tombe
sur une conversation qui va lui mettre
la puce à l'oreille
c'est donc de gamins qui discutent et il
y en a un qui qui écrit tu crois qu'il
s'est suicidé et l'élève avec qui
Alexandre avait des problèmes à l'école
répond j'espère
je me suis dit waouh enfin je veux dire
combien même on se réjouit pas de
l'amour d'un enfant quoi je me suis dit
là il y a quelque chose de pas normal
Gaëlle est choqué et blessé à la lecture
des mots si violents en remontant le fil
de la conversation elle découvre que les
échanges ont commencé à peine quelques
heures après le drame dès le samedi soir
il commençait déjà à parler entre eux du
décès d'Alexandre donc là j'ai été
énormément surprise puisque je me suis
dit hormis les secours ma famille je
veux dire on n'avait pas non plus
annoncer la nouvelle créer la nouvelle
sur les toits comme on dit c'est passé
en début d'après-midi le soir à 8h ils
étaient déjà au courant quasiment mieux
que nous
Bertrand Gerin vous êtes spécialiste de
la réputation numérique le harcèlement à
l'école semble avoir été aggravé cette
dernière année avec les réseaux sociaux
justement aujourd'hui avec le
l'ouverture du terrain de jeu digital où
les adolescents sont extrêmement
présents aujourd'hui le sujet ça devient
un nouveau champ de bataille sur le
harcèlement qui est à la maison dans sa
chambre qui est à dans sa chambre entre
4 murs jour et nuit même les jours où il
y a pas l'école
et puis il peut y avoir un phénomène de
buzz autour d'une personne un peu comme
les phénomènes moutonniers qu'on a dans
les cours récréations ça ça joue aussi
sur internet il y a beaucoup de choses
qu'on dit sur Internet qu'on n'oserait
pas dire dans la vraie vie c'est-à-dire
qu'on n'est pas en face des personnes
donc c'est plus facile d'une certaine
façon et puis derrière la personne elle
est toute seule dans sa chambre elle a
pas ses copains pour éventuellement le
rassurer le consoler donc il y a cette
solitude aussi d'une certaine façon qui
est qui aggrave potentiellement les
problèmes alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire pour sensibiliser les jeunes à ce
harcèlement sur Internet l'éducation
globalement les écoles doivent aussi je
pense essayer d'éduquer sensibiliser les
jeunes sur ces problématiques donc moi
je pense que il faudrait que dans les
cours on décolle les professeurs soient
formés et qui a un cours sur ces
problématiques de sensibilisation de
bonnes pratiques de ce qu'il faut faire
ce qu'il faut pas faire de relativiser
de donner des exemples les exemples
l'exemple de Jacky par exemple il est
très parlant ça parle tout de suite aux
jeunes et ils comprennent les enjeux
face à ces découvertes Gaëlle la mère
d'Alexandre décide de porter plainte
auprès des services de police
des investigations de son lancées mais
au bout de 10 jours seulement
l'enquêtez-vous bouclée
Gaëlle déterminée n'abandonne pas ses
recherches pour autant auprès des
camarades de classe de son fils elle
découvre alors le cauchemar quotidien
que vivait Alexandre
l'histoire rapportée par une petite
jeune fille qui nous expliquait qu'elle
attendait une amie à elle devant
l'établissement ici et que elle a vu
sortir
elle a vu sortir un petit gamin qu'elle
ne connaissait pas qui s'est fait huer
par une bande d'adolescents qui s'est
fait frapper et qu'à ce moment là elle
demande à son ami elle lui dit mais
c'est qui ce petit pourquoi il se fait
il se fait frapper et ça son ami qui
fait partie de l'établissement lui a dit
Oh écoute c'est rien c'est normal c'est
Alexandre tranchant comme si c'était
voilà normal qui se fasse frapper et que
ces choses habituelles quoi
insulte humiliation raquette quotidien
coût à répétition la terrible réalité
transparaît à travers les dires des
jeunes témoins face à ces révélations
Gaëlle est rongé par la culpabilité
en le posant voilà en le posant là tous
les matins j'ai surtout le sentiment de
l'avoir
l'avoir amené à la mort quoi il y a pas
d'autres mots c'est voilà c'est
d'ailleurs ces murs qui vivent un
cauchemar et c'est aussi derrière les
portes du collège que Gaëlle va tenter
de trouver de nouvelles réponses en
questionnant la direction de
l'établissement mais très vite elle est
confrontée à une administration qui
refuse de l'aider dans ses recherches
c'est manuels scolaires sont toujours à
la maison on m'a jamais appelé pour les
réclamer ses affaires parce qu'il avait
un petit casier à l'intérieur de l'école
je sais même pas où elles sont personne
m'a appelé pour me dire vous avez des
affaires à récupérer rien du tout ça a
été à partir de ce moment là ça a été
pour toute chose
face au manque de réponses des autorités
Gaëlle se sont seuls et perdus elle
s'effondre et s'enferment dans sa
douleur
alors Gaëlle nous raconte qu'après la
mort de son fils elle a eu beaucoup de
difficultés à avoir des réponses de la
part de l'école c'est la double peine
des victimes qui est on est victime de
déceler mais on se sent victime de
l'école qui nous entend pas ou
quelquefois simplement parce qu'on est
obligé de changer d'école ça n'est pas
normal il faut lutter contre ça peut-on
considérer qu'il y a une responsabilité
directe ou indirecte de l'école dans le
harcèlement alors effectivement le
harcèlement à l'école qui se passe en
milieu scolaire uniquement milieu
scolaire je pense que l'école a une
responsabilité il faut savoir que la loi
donc a été promulguée le 8 juillet 2013
fait obligation à tous les
établissements scolaires toutes les
écoles savoir de leur projet pédagogique
la prévention et la lutte contre le
harcèlement à l'école et ce sera évalué
mais le harcèlement ne s'arrête pas au
mur de l'école on peut plus dire il y a
le harcèlement à l'école le harcèlement
dans le que le jeu privé qui serait la
famille il faut une alliance des adultes
à ce niveau-là il faut une alliance
éducative réelle entre les parents et
l'école ça c'est un vrai combat c'est un
vrai combat où il faut vraiment aller
très loin dans l'ouverture là-dessus aux
familles il faut les croire il faut les
écouter il faut les aider l’école peut
pas porter plainte lorsque par exemple
il y a une intrusion dans l'espace privé
qu'est la page facebook c'est aux
parents à le faire mais on peut
l'expliquer on peut montrer les
procédures on peut dire quels sont les
aides c'est tout ça qui est en jeu
et sa tentative de suicide
[Musique]
plutôt que de toute avouer il va trouver
de nouvelles parades pour éviter au
maximum les confrontations avec ses
harceleurs
pour éviter le retour en bus il se rend
régulièrement à l'infirmerie pour que
ses parents viennent le chercher en
voiture
l'infirmière m'a appelé pour me dire
qu'il avait mal à la tête donc j'étais
le chercher après m'a appelé pour me
dire qu'il avait mal aux jambes donc
j'étais le chercher et c'est là où je me
suis rendu compte à la maison qu'il
allait très très bien quoi
donc il y avait un souci quoi sa mère
demande à Jacky des explications il lui
avoue alors se faire brutaliser dans le
car furieuse elles seront immédiatement
chez le proviseur celui-ci prend note de
l'affaire mais lui avoue son impuissance
face à des violences qui se produisent
en dehors de l'établissement à ce
moment-là j'aurais pu tout dire dans le
bureau
je l'ai pas fait parce que voilà je sais
pas voilà pareil de représailles tout ça
et je me suis dit on a trop dit avec le
bus on va pas non plus on y retrouve
toujours effrayé par ses agresseurs
l'adolescence enferme dans son mutisme
la fin de l'année se poursuit dans la
souffrance et les non-dits
alors qu'il s'apprête à rentrer en 5ème
les parents de Jacky lui annoncent
qu'ils vont déménager à Meaux en
banlieue parisienne
j'appréhendais parce qu'il venait d'un
collège pour moi assez tranquille et un
mot c'était quand même un collège
difficile quoi donc c'est vrai que là
j'ai eu très peur
pour Jacky ce changement d'établissement
est avant tout un immense soulagement
mais il ne peut pas s'empêcher d'être
inquiet à l'idée d'intégrer ce nouveau
collège situé dans une zone sensible
[Musique]
c'est vrai que j'avais extrêmement peur
parce que je me suis dit on va repartir
dans une année en plus voilà c'est zone
éducation prioritaire donc ça va voilà
et la surprise a été que j'ai eu des
cours et des
amis extraordinaires et c'est justement
lors d'un je me suis mis un peu à
pleurer j'ai eu les larmes aux yeux et
je leur ai tout raconté tout ce qui
m'était arrivé pendant la fin de là donc
les élèves
à la fin de ça ils se sont levés ils ont
tout simplement dit
touché par le calvaire vécu par leurs
camarades les élèves du collège font
tout pour intégrer Jacky
le délégué m'a tout de suite fait
visiter le bâtiment il m'a présenté à
d'autres élèves au prof
et c'est à ce moment-là que je me suis
dit que moi aussi je voulais être
délégué pour aider les élèves dans mon
cas
ça a été une sorte de petit déclic
[Musique]
cet épisode va permettre à Jacky de se
révéler à lui-même
[Musique]
déterminez à trouver des réponses à la
disparition de son fils Gaëlle souffre
du manque de coopération des personnes
vers qui elle se tournent pour se
défouler et vider son esprit elle
s'oblige à se rendre quotidiennement à
la salle de sport
[Musique]
c'est aussi là qu'elle retrouve des
personnes qui la soutiennent comme
Rebecca qui touchait par son histoire va
se révéler être un soutien capital je
suis dans un premier temps
voilà qu'elle avait perdu Alexandra et
puis j'ai su mais vraiment
quinze jours après le pourquoi vraiment
j'étais pas au courant du pourquoi et ça
ça m'a ça m'a révolté en fait
indigné par une situation intolérable
Rebecca décide d'organiser une marche de
soutien en la mémoire d'Alexandre 200
personnes sont présentes lors de cette
marche blanche cette marche blanche a
été un déclic quoi c'est c'est voilà de
se rendre compte
que effectivement il y a des gens qui
l'aimaient beaucoup et puis sentir la
mobilisation aussi des gens qui étaient
là c'est de se dire on n'a pas le droit
nous de laisser tomber
face à cette forte mobilisation Gaëlle
et Gilles se sentent plus soutenues que
jamais et décide de reprendre le combat
pour l'honneur de leur fils
à présent Gaëlle et Gilles se sont
tournés vers un avocat leur but que
l'enquête reprenne camarades de classe
ou école ils veulent trouver des
réponses
de poursuite harcèlement morale nous
allons provocation à suicide sur ces
recommandations tous les membres de la
famille se constituent participent une
nouvelle plainte pour relancer l'affaire
grâce à cette action en justice Gaëlle
espère que l'histoire d'Alexandre ne
tombera pas dans l'oubli et que les
langues se déliront enfin
c'est aussi pour lui parce que
voilà si qui soit pas parti pour rien
qui n'est pas fait ça pour rien
que s'il a choisi cette solution extrême
c'est que il en a pas trouvé d'autres
donc oui c'est c'est lui reconnaître
c'est une victime
mais pour le couple tranchant c'est
aussi un combat pour faire reconnaître
le harcèlement scolaire comme un délit
[Musique]
S
quelque chose contre le harcèlement à
l'école
et le harcèlement c'est quoi c'est un
bisbutage mais qui dure toute l'année
qui dure pas sur trois jours
[Musique]
vous êtes avocat dans le cas d'Alexandre
l'éducation nationale peut-elle être
condamnée
il faut déposer la plage et il
appartient au parquet au procureur
d'analyser au cas par cas quelle est la
situation et pourquoi ces adultes ces
professionnels ne sont pas intervenus il
faut savoir que quand un enfant est à
l'école il y a la notion de transfert de
droit de garde et donc ce sont les
enseignants qui sont gardiens et donc ce
sont les enseignants qui sont civilement
responsables de ce qui se passe à
l'école et au-delà des enseignants toute
la hiérarchie alors condamner oui
condamné à quoi le problème de la sens
de la peine est un autre débat à quoi
faut-il condamner mais oui je pense
qu'il faut condamner ça semble très
compliqué de mêler le milieu judiciaire
et le milieu scolaire pourquoi parce que
traditionnellement on pense que ça doit
se régler au sein de l'école longtemps
on a pensé que la violence scolaire
était quelque chose d'assez marginal
aujourd'hui on se rend compte grâce à
des enquêtes sérieuses que plus d'un
enfant sur dix est victime de ces
violences et de harcèlement moral est-ce
qu'on prendrait aussi en compte les
violences qui se passent à la sortie de
l'école il se passe à l'extérieur
de harcèlement on le voit très bien dans
le film ça se passe dans l'école et ça
se passe à l'extérieur de l'école et la
souffrance et la même pour ses enfants
c'est un véritable enfer sauf qu'ils
sont tellement culpabilisés qu'ils osent
pas en parler et parce qu'ils osent pas
en parler ben finalement ils vont
retourner la violence non pas contre
leur agresseur mais contre même
devenu délégué de classe au collège
Jacky s'épanouit auprès de ses nouveaux
camarades
mais c'est à son arrivée au lycée que
l'investissement de Jacky dans la vie
scolaire et le plus spectaculaire
en plus de ces activités de délégués il
va mettre en place un journal télévisé
et une cérémonie de récompenses
avril l'une de ses amis se souvient du
jeune homme avec émotion
c'est un garçon qu'on voyait tout de
suite puisque justement il avait un
naturel très joyeux très expansif et
c'est quelqu'un qu'on remarqué de suite
et avec qui on avait envie d'aller il
était il était très drôle et donc enfin
je crois que tout le monde voulait être
son ami un peu
révoltez en apprenant ce qu'il a subi en
sixième les amis de Jacky le pousse à
raconter son expérience
Jacky qui n'a jamais déposé plainte
décide d'écrire un livre
à la base j'ai créé pas dans le but de
le publier j'écrivais juste parce que
justement j'ai envie
et au final ensuite quand j'ai fait lire
à mes amis et que j'ai vu que ça
plaisait c'est là que j'ai tenté de le
de le publier puis ça a mis deux ans
Jacky
mère la lecture
d'une de son fils est une révélation
elle est bouleversée quand j'ai lu le
livre c'est vrai que
j'ai pleuré quoi parce que surtout qui
parle d'un épisode où il a pensé au
suicide quoi donc
en tant que maman c'est pas possible
quoi donc
vraiment je crois que c'est pour ça que
j'étais enfin j'étais en colère aussi
vraiment colère souffrance et
culpabilité quoi
[Musique]
dans la continuité de son livre et avec
l'aide de ses amis Jacquie a décidé de
monter une association afin de lutter
contre le harcèlement scolaire dans
quelques semaines il va commencer sa
vague de prévention en organisant des
discussions dans les classes de sixième
et c'est au sein du collège Georges
Brassens là où il a lui-même été victime
que Jacky va symboliquement commencer
son action
[Musique]
aujourd'hui Jacky va mieux mais cet
épisode la profondément marqué jusqu'à
influencer ses choix de vie il vient
d'intégrer la faculté de droit de
Montpellier pour réaliser son rêve et
devenir procureur
[Musique]
Gaëlle et Gilles sont toujours dans
l'attente d'une décision de justice
malgré leur chagrin ils savent que le
combat le plus dur à mener sera de
continuer à vivre sans leur fils bien
aimé